foreign
[Music]
Memorial outside of Rob Elementary
School in Uvalde Texas as we mark one
year since that terrible school shooting
there the families of those killed still
grieving also still looking for answers
it was May 24th 11 33 a.m when a gunman
went into that school killed 19 children
and two teachers inside of fourth grade
classroom and officers waited outside
for one hour and 17 minutes through
their continued grief the families have
found strength in calling for changes in
gun laws demanding more school safety
and greater accountability Lily Luciano
has been covering this tragedy for the
past year and she joins us once again
from Uvaldi a place she now knows quite
well Lilia good morning
let's write a tough morning here Tony
look it took weeks months for the school
police chief to be fired months of
protest of leaks then more time for the
school superintendent to finally step
down here in Uvalde that time continued
going on and families kept asking for
more accountability now there's a new
superintendent who tells us that the
school district has poured millions of
dollars into security that includes
about 600 cameras across campus that
includes building fences but for the
families that we continue to hear from
the from the families who lost their
children they say the needle hasn't
moved nearly enough and for them life is
still stuck on May 24th of last year
because I was just like too scared and
think about anything for Andrea rera
surviving the mass shooting in Uvalde is
still a daily recurrence he just goes in
my mind just making Loops like the same
clip over and over again
she was not only at Rob Elementary that
day but her stepbrother 10 year old Jose
Flores was killed in the classroom next
door I was like excited to see him
it's definitely just was ready to honk
him
and one more time he said he didn't make
it like and I started crying and
I couldn't believe it happened like
Andrea
who we first met with her other brother
Jaden just two days after the shooting
is still haunted by the thought of who
says whereabouts during the shooting I
was the middle child but I was more
braver than him so you're worried about
how scared he was that day yeah
like during the classroom I always
imagined him like how he like how his
face is and he's scared Andrea's mother
Cynthia says her kids mental health and
school performance keeps declining
and the tension in town increasing does
it ever make you want to leave yes for
sure why are you still here
well because he's here awesome yeah
and it's harder just to pick up and
leave Red Cross Too is Tethered to
Uvalde after burying his ten-year-old
uziah Garcia if I stop
I'm useless for cross leaving Uvalde
would also mean giving up on a year-long
fight for answers and change to do what
is right one he has led at the local
state and federal level Uvalde don't
want to be known as Uvalde anymore they
don't want it to be oh we're known for
Rob Elementary
but the fact is that you are because our
school failed because our cops failed
because our government felt and you want
me to stop
I've lost the kid I ain't got anything
else to lose perhaps the most pressing
failure
376 Law Enforcement Officers for more
than 20 agencies waiting for 77 minutes
before breaching through a classroom
door how do you describe to people who
are not living here day to day what the
relationship is like with police
there were officers in there that could
have ended it but were told to stand
down and they listened and then you see
them you get pulled over by them
that's happened to you yeah it's
infuriating because now I'm looking in
the eyes of somebody that hurt our
children screaming
that heard the gunman reload and didn't
rush in there to mend the broken trust
the mayor of Vivaldi Don Mclaughlin
recently hired an assistant police chief
from outside the town but like the
families of the victims McLaughlin is
still waiting for results from the local
District Attorney's criminal
investigation of the 25 officers that
were according to the legislative
investigation at the school that day how
many are still
protecting this town father resign 20
are still on the force and again it goes
back when we can complete our
investigation does that make sense to
you that it's taken a year where we have
not seen anything from the D.A as mayor
and I think I speak for the County Judge
too
I'm not going to just throw uh
everything to D.A but in one year's time
I've had not one briefing not one
we asked the district attorney about
that criminal investigation she told us
that it's still in the hands of the
Texas Rangers from the DPS she says once
that's completed and it gets to her
office her office will review it and
present any potential charges to a
Uvalde grand jury but until she receives
it from DPS from the Texas Rangers she
doesn't even know whether any charges
will be presented Tony
oh boy Lilia you know I mentioned at the
top that you've been there a lot over
the past year it's a place you know
quite well uh because of that I want to
ask you what have you noticed about that
Community uh this year has gone by what
has struck you most about where they are
in their process of recovery
well Tony of course the list is endless
but one thing that really struck me
about Uvalde is that when it happened
the community came together everywhere
you go there's a Uvalde strong poster
but among those families the families
who lost their kids what they tell me is
that there's a deep division whether
it's because of politics whether it's
because of their protests demanding
accountability it seems that people
within their Community not everyone some
but also across the country expect them
to move on they say we can't even take
the first step because we don't even
know what happened yet and from Andrea I
just heard the most heartbreaking thing
she just told us I wish people knew what
it was like to be there and also lose
your brother
Lily A continuing tremendous reporting
there from Uvalde Texas in front of that
Memorial now one year later Lily thank
you very much